what's my zodiac sign again wait I
thought it was a rooster hey mom can you
make me those noodles with the meat that
I like the next time I come home can you
send me the recipe for chicken tikka
masala again you mind sending needs the
recipe to make far how do you reheat
rice
did you hear what unneeded how old is
grandma right when is your birthday what
type of Tiger ball should what type of
noodle should I get there's a different
tree can we go to the Asian market
together what was it like growing up in
Laos what's the name of the city you
were from again do we have family in
Singapore what's Korean Thanksgiving
what's the difference between Lao New
Year and regular year how do I read my
Chinese name again so I know you gave me
the recipe but is it supposed to be
burning like this how do I say toilet
paper in love what does kili kili made
someone said mine looked weird can I
borrow some of your jewelry this weekend
no I'm not dating anyone I'm not dating
anyone right now no mom I'm not dating
anybody
no I don't want to go to Temple to meet
anybody else No